hey guys what's up this is andrew for
consensus.com
i'm a professional trader and i'm here
to teach you everything i know about
technical analysis
so what i like to do is to use all my
preferred indicators
one by one and see the signals that
they're giving me so today let's make an
analysis on amc
let's get into it
[Music]
all right guys let's start on the first
time frame as usual
so this is you know the drawing i did on
my last video
what is interesting is to see if yes or
not
this scenario which is for now my
preferred scenario but of course
when we gonna have more data this
scenario would probably be
slightly updated or maybe completely
wrong
i don't know yet i'm gonna keep these
drawings and i'm gonna update it
each time i have some new information so
let's start on the first time frame
and let's quickly sum up what happened
the whole week i was basically you know
calling for some
bullish momentum to come back for some
strong moves up
since i had my breakout here on the 15th
of april and i was telling you that this
looks like to me we are in a third wave
so
in blue here right so on a longer time
frame we are in the third wave and we
are just doing a one two one two and
this
should be a three so we are actually in
the third wave that should be in
positive and c
and have bigger volumes training so the
volumes are slightly increasing but
they're not big guys same as for
gamestop
those two stocks uh used to have very
strong volumes trading you know even
here in march and it's just going lower
lower lower all right
but the good thing is that the price
section is going lower too so we don't
have a divergence
in volumes i mean compared to the
highest level we had here if we had here
a higher high
and here volumes going lower this would
be a divergence this would not be good
for now this is just you know a
correction that
is to me finishing but we are not seeing
the
very bullish signals that we're gonna
have in the third wave when it's gonna
really start but we're having it a
little bit so now if i go back on the
four hours time frame
i'm gonna try to analyze if all that
happened here is
actually making my scenario changing do
i need to update
so i added this now i was like this guys
all right
i was like this in my last video and i
was telling you that this is a very
healthy abc
because you know i was using fibs for
those who have watched this video and i
was telling you that you know about 50
so the 1060 level it was like this
all right whatever 10 55 now i'm having
maybe
okay 1060. it was like this i was
telling you that
above 50 we are bullish this correction
abc of this first
move up in orange is actually healthy
and normal and this is what we are
expecting the third wave
and i told you that maybe we're gonna go
to 10 20 but i don't think we're gonna
go lower
well we did go lower so just by looking
at the fibs this is not good
but that's why i like to use iliad guys
because iliot is actually more precise
it is going to use the kind of same
reasoning of retracements but it's not
basic level using the golden number
ratio but it's actually depending on
how the first wave was built so here
it's important
to actually let's go into our little
frame and it's important to label this
properly
all right so let's do it together i'm
going to do the abc later
all right the one two three four five
guys that i have here
is kind of obvious it's one two
three four five third wave cannot be the
shortest but it's not here the biggest
all right the biggest wave is the fifth
wave so this is what is
not usual in this first wave i mean it's
fine it is still respecting all the
eliot rules
but you can see that the fifth wave is
very strong and we're having a kind of
unusual first wave so why not having an
unusual second wave and i'm gonna
explain what i mean
usually idiot wave counting is giving
you
two levels of potential correction for
the second wave either
we are correcting to the top of the
third wave which is here
as you can see 1065
and it's actually working better than
fibs because
you can see that the 1065 level on the
hourly timeframe was the support level
it was not 1060
so illiot was correct idiot or you know
trend lines this goes together
but it's actually the top of the third
wave that was supporting the price in
the move down
then it broke and we actually now
went where okay the false wave is
actually here
going to 980 so this is
actually my level you know
the situation would be very different
once again it can also happen that one
two waves are just doing something like
this you can have almost 100 percent of
retracement and still it's going to be
valid
but guys we are in the third wave why
not having this in the first wave but
not in the third wave
so here if you go below the 980 level
mass scenario would need to be very
different
now let's analyze this
second wave deeper so we always do the
same thing as
checking what information the market is
giving us so here
a b
and c and here when i do things like
this
because i was seeing an abc like this
guys but actually the c
wave has been longer but
c waves always contain five waves so
let's see if we find five waves here
you know abc is three three five you're
gonna find different information about
that
in the book i found three three five and
this is what i see in the market
so i need to find five waves here and
it's interesting to notice that i
actually have my five waves this could
be
the end of the second wave but once
again for the second wave to be
finished as usual guys what is going to
give us the signal
this trend line right this strong line
connecting the highs
of this abc and let me put it
in orange so this trend line guys
this is what you're looking for all
right if you day trader if you want to
buy amc
for example so of course you can buy the
dip but what i suggest
what i like to do my method is actually
to buy the price
when it's starting to go higher so here
the typical situation
if this is correct if actually this abc
is finished and i have
five waves here here have three waves
here i have three waves
so this is kind of a typical abc i
should have here
something like this all right so we're
gonna break it
then retest it and then we're gonna go
higher so this level would be on monday
10 25 if we see amc training around 10
20 10 25
on monday like let's say after
four or five hours here just for the
time period to be filled
then we would have another signal that
the second wave is complete
and we're probably gonna have some more
bullish signals coming
so for now this scenario is still my
preferred scenario
and one more thing i like to do guys is
to
try to see if i have any divergence on
the uh short term
because once again here we are bullish
this is kind of obvious
since we had this breakout since 8 we
are bullish so if we are bullish
and suddenly the price action is
supposed to shift then
most of the time we having some
divergences so let's see if we have any
because if we do then we need to keep
this in mind and
just accept that we're having some
bullish signals and some bearish signals
so to do that let's start on the forest
time frame very quickly
let me show you what is divergence i
like to talk about divergences uh this
past days because
this is more complex tool than i usually
show you guys
and i think that most of you are ready
to see it so we are looking for this
because now we are in a bullish
development so we're trying to see if
something is telling us that we are
bearish alright this is what we need
to look for to be professional and to
really
do the technical analysis job properly
so we're looking for
higher highs mandy going lower or lower
highs might be going higher all right
this would be bearish so let's see if we
have it once again
very easy guys i'm here to give you some
tips guys so
looking for divergences may seem
difficult for you but the way i do it
there is nothing difficult you know you
just connect the highs
connect the lows and check what is the
macd doing connect the highs
then check the macd connect the lows
check the macd let's do it
i connect the lows first and i check the
macd between here
and here so here is the 30th of april
13th of april the macd is here and
here nights now so market making high
lows
maxi going higher so no divergence all
right it's the same direction
now let's do the same exact thing with
the highs
so it's going to be the same thing we
check but
different days so between the 15th of
april this time and
the 27th of april all right 15th of
april
we're here and 27th of april we're here
so market making higher highs might be
going higher
so no divergence on the forest timeframe
now
let's you know really check everything
let's go on hourly time frame
but on the hourly timeframe we're
already bearish so we are here you know
we are bearish because this is bearish
so the magazine is going lower the
market is making higher low
lower lows lower highs and no bullish
divergence on the short term
so here we cannot check
this no we can only do it on the first
time frame you understand why
on the hourly time frame i would be here
looking for bullish divergences because
on the hourly time frame the momentum is
bearish you can see the macd is going
lower
so here i'm looking for bullish
divergences that i don't have for now
because macd is going lower market
making lower highs lower lows so no
divergence
so for now there is nothing that is
telling me that the market is going to
bounce back
except what i did before using idiot
wave counting and
using my trend lines
so to conclude on this
my preferred scenario is still valid we
just corrected a bit deeper than
expected
we are waiting for more volumes guys all
right this is
crucial this is what we need to see and
if we break the
980 level you know this is not a third
wave definitely this
could only be something weaker than a
third wave so then we would need to
reassess the analysis
and we would probably go on the wxy
correction something like this
all right okay so if we don't have here
a third wave
it means that we're having something
like this this is the alternative
scenario
that is for now not on the table that is
for now
not my preferred scenario everything
that i see here even if we had some
weakness on thursday and friday
last week is still showing me bullish
signals
and the bullish case that i have here
is still my preferred scenario so yes
that's it for me i hope you enjoyed this
video and if you did please don't forget
to click on the sub like and bell button
so you're gonna be the first to know
when i upload anything
new and stay close to shore see you guys